often times people ask me how I can
invest so much time into one thing
movies why I have such a passion for
cinema and how I can force myself to sit
there nearly every film that comes out
each year whether it be great good or a
disaster but sometimes what people don't
realize is when that one movie comes
along that one movie that gives us film
buffs that hide that we're searching for
it gives us that feeling that we've just
discovered some kind of secret riches
that only us know about and no one else
has yet to find it's that feeling that
we cherish that ultimate high that we
movie lovers yearn for to experience
when we go and we sit down in that dark
room I want to share with you why I love
movies what they mean to me and what
movies help me develop as a movie lover
when I was growing up the movies I was
shown shaped me into the man I am today
and gave me some of the best memories of
my life watching the Dread Pirate
Roberts sword fight with inigo montoya
listening to him recite what he would do
when he meets his father's killer my
name is Inigo Montoya you killed my
father prepare to die experiencing the
thrill of time travel and hearing this
great line for the very first time being
transported to a faraway land where
space was a war zone and the force was
the mystical power of the entire
universe letting the thrill of adventure
wash over me as I saw what is to this
day my favorite chase sequence in any
film ever seeing movies like that made
me want to do it for myself I wanted to
direct my own films I wanted to share my
love with others help other people to
experience those same feelings that I
felt when I watched movies
I continued to love movies as I grew but
it wasn't until the year 2002 where
everything changed for me I went with my
mom to see a film called signs a movie
that owned a surface looked like a fun
alien invasion movie but for that
14-year old sitting in that theater
holding his knees peeking out over them
it proved to be something far more it
was the first film I ever saw where it
struck me that there was a man behind
that camera there was an editor a gaffer
an assistant director a costume designer
a director photography when I got home
from seeing signs I told myself that's
what I want to do I want to be a
filmmaker
I started making my own short films any
idea that popped into my head no matter
what it was I literally went out and
filmed it I forced my friends into every
project that came into my head no matter
how ludicrous it was
[Music]
through signs I grew a serious fondness
for scary movies and to this day after
every winter when it starts getting warm
outside something inside me tells me to
go on a scary movie binge there are few
things more exciting and fun than a
movie that can scare the Wits out of you
and make you enjoy it at the same time I
began to appreciate all different types
of movies not just the fun adventures
but more sophisticated filmmaking movies
that could touch your heart and your
soul movies came along as I grew that
changed my life that made me look at
things differently give me a new idea of
what a filmmaker could do behind the
camera I had always loved reviewing
movies having written short user reviews
on Yahoo the movies and starting a
short-lived now-dead webpage called a
critics opinion if I ever meet someone
who remembers that page I will hug them
eventually I discovered YouTube and I
was drawn into this wonderful group of
people who loved movies as much as I do
I found other people who felt the same
their passions were my passions they
were all looking for that same high that
I was looking for the thrill of seeing
that one movie that comes along that
sends adrenaline through your veins that
reminds you why you go to the movies why
you wait in line that movie that no
matter what your age makes you jump up
and down with excitement because it
reminded you of being a kid again it
made you feel young again it made you
just have that high they were all
looking for that movie that when you
leave it you're like yes that is why I
do this that is what all these people
were looking for just like me
all of these experiences through life
I've shaped me into the movie lover I am
today and even though I loosely used the
term film critic when people ask me what
I do I don't view myself that way
because there's a difference between
someone who loves movies and a film
critic someone who loves movies waits in
line for hours awaiting the premiere of
their most anticipated movie they stock
their shelves full of DVDs and blu-rays
some even VHS they save all of their
movie tickets just so they can remember
the memories they want to immediately
chat with their friends about the movie
they just saw because
there are a few things more fun to them
than sharing their opinions on film
that's why no matter what anyone else
refers to me as I will always be a movie
lover
ever since my parents sat me in front of
that TV and I saw those yellow words
blast onto the screen
I have loved movies and I always will
[Music]